ce soir je reçois un appel au bout du
fil l'homme parle anglais
il se présente comme un employé de
microsoft
vous êtes bien johan la tulipe du 22 22
rue des lilas dit il l'air de vouloir
vérifier son identité
l'homme dit ensuite à johan que
microsoft a remarqué des problèmes dans
son ordinateur
vous avez probablement été la cible de
pirates a ajouté
il demande ensuite à johan de démarrer
son ordinateur et les hits cet inconnu
est il vraiment un représentant de lits
consorts
johan a raison de se méfier c'est
probablement une arnaque déjà dénoncée
par la grc et par microsoft
sans la vigilance de johan ce fraudeur
aurait pu prendre le contrôle de son
ordinateur
il aurait ensuite nous y installer un
logiciel qui ni vu ni connu aurait
capturé les noms d'utilisateurs et mots
de passe
une manoeuvre qui lui aurait donné accès
aux comptes bancaires de joie le fin mot
de l'histoire comme vous l'ont dit et
répété vos parrains dit non aux inconnus